Look right into the cameras at the thing to do or look at you or get me yeah, great
Okay, today is March 7th 2017 and we were with Stephen Strauss who's a distinguished professor of
Forests Technology at OSU
And we will talk to him a fair amount about his career and his time at OSU
I'd like to begin by building more of a biographical sketch of your life and ask you where were you born
I was born in Brooklyn, New York
Is that where you grew up?
I was there until I was 16 and I left for college at that point and
Never went back really into various schools and places of employment, but
Not back there since I started college
Tell me about the Brooklyn of your childhood
Well, you know, I had a very simple upbringing, you know, my parents then I had a lot of money
And they also was the fourth child
And by the time they got to me they were sort of done being
uh
Careful caretakers. So I really had my
One of the streets as it were I traveled around New York City on the subways and buses extensively and
Pretty much called the shots came to one as I wanted so I was a bit of a feral kid
So that was fun
Tell me a bit about your parents and your family got crowded. Yeah my
My father was a postal worker second half of his life and
Worked evenings and enjoyed his job a great deal and had a great network of friends
And I think he enjoyed being there than more than enjoyed being home
With the kids and with my mom
My mom was a hard worker, but she was sitting overwhelmed I think by the depression and raising two kids and
Was sort of mentally run out. Let's say with the time she got to me. So
You know very humble simple upbringing, you know, my parents had good values and still didn't me
You know ten times over the value of getting an education and making yourself better and help me all along the way once they
Realized I had good academic potential. They kept finding money
They didn't think they had to keep my academic career going so solid upbringing, but also not a great deal of
Mentoring advisement, you know any of the things that I hope I've given to my kids
Having a better situation
Can you tell me a bit more about community life and the specific neighborhood that you were in what neighborhood was that?
It was neighborhood called Barrow Park in New York. It was split roughly 50-50
between
Quite religious Jews many of the Pacific and you know dressed in all the garb and refusing to associate really with
What you might call mainstream society and then Italians and many of those were Sicilians who were first or one and a half
Generations off the boat and they were rough and tough and tumble and
hated Jews as much as the Jews hated them and I grew up with most of my friends who I had a
secular type of life my parents were Jewish but very reform
Nothing like the acidic Jews. I was something of an in-betweener
Where I played with these kids. I was out in the street playing stick ball and football and
You know just just was Italian friends who didn't know what to make of me
Because they were taught to hate Jews and I was a Jew but not really a Jew because I wasn't like those guys
And so it was a a strange upbringing that required
But but some of these these Italian friends are still very close to me even at the stage of my life
And so it was you know as they were struggling with many of them over
Getting brutalized at home. I mean, that was normal for this Sicilian culture
They came from they came came in five minutes late and they were getting beaten
And I had a very different kind of upbringing
So it was quite amazing to see that
See the acidic Jews see my in-betweener kind of
Growing up and figure it out from there
What were you interested in as you're as before growing up?
Well, you know the big I was interested in sports. I was just a very active sporty kid
I still run I referee soccer. I still you know, I follow some of the OSU teams
So I'm still a sporty guy
So these Italians were very athletic and so that was a real connection
And then probably the big change was you know, it was a gut to a teenage years
And I started I met friends who were somewhat politically active in protesting
being on board
Being interested in recreational marijuana and things that were very common in the generation back then
So I really I moved away from these Italian kids and move further away
After my bar mitzvah I did get that done because I felt like the family needed me to do that
And then I moved away from Judaism moved away from these Italian more rough elements and found a group of friends
That you know were more intelligent. They were a mix of
Jews and Gentiles, but more you would say progressive or left leaning and grew my hair along
I had beads
In junior high school, I remember that started and became you know
Fairly politically active one to a bunch of demonstrations
As a high schooler and then into college
At what point did science became chem something was important to you
Yeah, you know, I had I went to a high school in Brooklyn called Brooklyn Tech
So New York City there's three selective public high schools
And Brooklyn Tech is one of the three where there's an entrance exam
And it was it's really a place for training engineers
And in the old school engineers were people who just shut up and calculated
And the teaching of science was rough
I mean for people who were gifted and mathematics, I guess it was okay
But I was completely turned off to science. I wanted no part of it
All the teachers the whole education system was
The opposite of sort of my somewhat progressive interests
So when I so I graduated I did take the engineering classes
I had to at Brooklyn Tech and did fine
And then when I got to college I went to the state university in New York
I purchased which is sort of an alternative arm of the state university system in New York
Didn't have grades had all kinds of
experimental
Teaching systems, I majored in philosophy for a year
Or just trying to figure out what I was interested in and so forth
And really because I was interested in the environment
And with the save the world
And I didn't see how a degree in philosophy was going to really help me do that
And I was concerned about my economic disability to survive
So I switched to biology at that point to the interest in the environment and some kind of a job
And then I got into the science track
I was also I had skipped a grade in middle school junior high school as we called it
I was born at the end of the year
So I was almost two years immature compared to a lot of my peers
And I was really confused in college
So I was going through these transitions, philosophy, environment, science and just
And using a lot of marijuana and other things and I was just
So finally I said time out, I took a year off
And that was a really smart thing to do
And worked, saved money, did some great traveling, went to Alaska
And was friends and other things and then when I went back
I was able to transfer to Cornell and become a serious science student
And Cornell was very, very rigorous
And so really from then till now I've just been bussed in my ass, if you will
Trying to keep up with the incredible pace and demands of being a scientist
That's interesting, I was going to ask about how a kid from Brooklyn
Becomes somebody who spends his career in the forest and it sounds like it immerse out of this
This political impulse
Political impulse and along with that I began to backpack some with some friends
When you think about the fires, I remember being very curious
You know, what's this tree?
You know, who knows, what does it do?
And so I got curious about it, I loved the outdoors
There was an element of use of drugs in there that made me sort of just worship in a religious sense
I had some experience with friends that were just, you know
I still think of this day, these friends of ours
Friends of mine, you know, talk about how
How
Magical it was to sort of see the environment, love the environment, be out there, bond
Try to understand it, try to think about being a caretaker of the environment
And so it was inspirational
It was what it was, you know, all that infusion of the youth and the
The feeling of the need to save the environment and then with sort of recreational
Uses and drugs in the comradeship, I just became passionate about it
So it's
I don't want to overemphasize a drug part of it except that it gave a great sense of joy and
Sort of sharing that you know, what happened anyway, but maybe it was more intense
Yeah, how did you select Cornell or did the Cornell select you?
Well, I selected Cornell, you know, with my limited
Knowledge base growing up in Brooklyn and my parents, you know, working class and the other one of them had a college education
You know, we always assume the next thing you do is go to Brooklyn College or some very affordable nearby place
Because you couldn't possibly afford to go to high out of town school at a long Cornell
And my sister was sort of five years ahead of me and she said if it broke in the the thinking shackles
That you know, we could do better that we could retire and she encouraged me to apply and one thing nice about Cornell
It's very selective, but there's also it's a hybrid really between a state supported
University and a private university and biology is actually split
I think it still is there
So if you get into biology and you're a resident of the state of New York, your tuition is about half
So I made it suddenly affordable whereas it wouldn't have been otherwise
And then I started getting a bunch of scholarships because I really worked hard and got very good grades
And then like I said and when my father realized that I was getting a A's at Cornell who was this kid he started just
Paying off debts and stuff
It sounds like this is an important moment in your life Cornell. Yeah
Yeah, just it was the
The start of you know a whole new person that you know, wasn't this wasn't this kid in Brooklyn
But was someone who was going somewhere and
You know, I started working with an ecologist a Cornell
It's also taking all these courses in biology and evolution that you know blow your mind
You know and suddenly you're thinking about all this big big stuff and
Also thinking about saving the world and
You know, I still never saw myself as a professor or a scientist. I just really I'm able to do that
But you know, I get a degree and then I think well a great. I have a bachelor's now
What do I do with it in the world of biology you are a technician for somebody?
And then you think about well, I get a master's and it's really the same thing
And so it really be a scientist to be somebody who calls the shots whose thoughts and intellect and ideas
Or what drives what happens
You need to in science you need to move on to get PhD even beyond, you know, you need to get a postdoc
So I just never got off the train
Because I realized I needed to stay on it though. I never imagined myself
Being a scientist with my my humble upbringing. So it just kept going and I kept having success and uh and then from
Cornell I got into the Yale School of Forestry and Environment which is another not today
It's it's much more a
A breeding ground for environmental activists and policy people
So it's fully transition and then I went to Cal Berkeley after that, which is you know similar
And so I kept getting into these very challenging very great academic environments that were even more and more
Environmentally as well as scientifically
And the players on the world seen
How did you arrive at forest science is something you wanted to focus on from biology and guessing biology
Sort of an entry to you developing a scientific foundation
But then you focused your perspective a little bit from there. Yeah, that's a really interesting question
I think it was the fusion of backpacking and being out in the environment
I also remember when I was I think 17 I hitchhiked out from the east coast to the west coast and I was in Oregon
just as a long-haired kid by myself and I remember getting a a
A ride with a logger. I was up in the Oregon cascade somewhere near Salem
Not really knowing what I was doing
This is in May and I thought I was going to back that the pacifist crest to start back packing it those all under snow
And you know, I just didn't really know what I was doing
But I had this conversation with this logger
And I sort of told them about all the things I've read from the Sierra Club that helped bad
Fower forest we was in the northwest and how a clear cut is a sin that should never happen
And he just said now some let me tell you what we do it
Let me tell you what the safeguards are and I had no idea how one sided and biased a perspective
I was getting for from the Sierra Club
And that issue actually continues to this day as I worked in biotechnology where
you have
Organizations that I trusted as being truthful and telling the whole story. I'm not realize do not
And so that's that's one of the steps in my evolution from
Save the world simple scientist science will save the world to the real politics and real information society
We're in of course which has exploded of late with all the fake news and everything
But that's been going on forever to one degree or another just not a
Presidential level or quite so blatantly
But anyway that really opened my eyes got me interested. So what is really happening in forestry
And why do you clear? Okay, and we can be do it safely and can you use intensive technologies of all sorts
You know conscientiously and responsibly
Amidst all the noise and so that's a place that I continued to sort of work in for 30 years at OSU in the in the biotech
Controversy area later to true using agriculture in general
Back to Yale. Okay fest today. It was surprised to find out that they had a forest science program
Yeah, yeah most people don't know about it. Yeah, tell me about that environment from you for you
Yeah, you know, Yale was a I went there I
First because when I was a Cornell and I was interning to undergraduate research with a ecologist
And he was grooming me to go work with his PhD supervisor
brilliant man named herb Mormon an ecosystem biologist
And I was all set to go there and then my graduation was in delayed a year because I
I overlooked a requirement in my visor and so I had one so one more year to kind of figure out who I was
And I took a class in forestry and I just got a little more interested in sort of application and the near-term sense
And so when I got to Yale
To work to be an ecosystem ecologist in a train I work with her but I did work with her boyman son
But I I sort of veered off and became more of a
Physiologist practitioner as compared to an ecosystem ecologist
But I also discovered that Yale was a place where the number of sort of scientists
Particularly the number of practice you know practitioner type scientists is very small
I mean it had really transitioned 60s and 70s into a training ground for
Environmental activists environmental lawyers
You know a lot of the people who populate a lot of international organizations come through places like Yale and Duke forestry is done
Similar thing and Cal Berkeley forestry's done a similar thing where it really to
To survive and be a
College in those institutions that are not land grants
Or if they are there, you know, they're mostly not in Berkeley's case. They're kind of a split one
They really had to become really working on big issues of environmental science and a global sense
So they transitioned and there's still some science there in all these places, but it's relatively small
Or it's highly environmental and so it's you know and Oregon state still we have we have a lot of that too
But we also have a much bigger because we serve we're in this region with this incredible forestry sector
Whereas New Haven is not in such a region anymore
It's a little bit of forestry but very very little by comparison and so we here try to serve both
You know training students just to work in the industry work in the land management agencies very actively
As well as do science and be in the cutting edge of the environmental issues
So anyway, but being at Yale was very much a step into that world
Which is world I wanted to be in my whole life
But I also realized that I was a little naive maybe in thinking that science had more of the answers
And in reality, I found that science has a lot of answers, but mostly
The laws and social perceptions make it difficult to have those answers sort of be used
Particularly in genetics, which you know we can talk about at some point
Yeah, what was your research focus at that point?
Yeah, so at at Yale I did
I think two or three projects there were also Yale doesn't have a master's
thesis requirement
So I got involved in research projects. I went out to the US Forest Service in California
In Berkeley actually where they had the Pacific Southwest station their work with scientists there
And got my first paper was on the inheritance
So pines have these turquinoids that make them smell sonitis in the resin that comes down and tries to protect them from barked
Beasons and so forth. Well the chemistry of that rate that resin varies widely
And so sometimes you have one chemical sometimes another and it's important to the ecology and the organism
So I figured out how it's inherited
Some scientists before me Bill Critchfield a very, very great man had made these hybrids between different species
And the progeny then had high alpha pining, low alpha pining, and we're seeing all these chemicals
So he sort of did this basic
Meaning were crossing species with different chemistries that and then you could map the genes in the progeny
So he basically said here's the progeny you want to map the genes
And so I went out and measured them you know with help of the scientists and that was my first paper
And then there are a couple of other small projects like that
So really what it was very much being an apprentice in sciences like that a lot
Where you know people do projects over many years and then students and postdocs come in
And sort of figure it out at value to it tweak it
And particularly with trees but you know science in general or you know experiments take years to decades
And so I came into the stream of science that the farest science the farest service scientists were doing in Berkeley
I was able to publish in papers and that sort of set me up for
You know getting into grad school and in talent and success from there on was that your first exposure to tree genetics
I mean it's obviously yeah really and I yeah when I went to yellow was not as I told you it was to be an ecosystem scientist
And I started working for a geneticist there that put me on a couple of projects
And then he set up this opportunity with a far service in Berkeley, California name is Tom Lettig
He passed away from cancer a couple of years ago, but very very very well known internationally
And so
He and he was at Yale and then he moved to the farest service and so they set up those opportunities
So I went to Yale, you know, no particular interest in genetics
I was open to it and then the opportunities the people and then I went to Berkeley too, you know
That was partly to work with Tom Lettig, but I still was open to being a physiologist a
Siliculturist managing forests and a larger scale
Made in a college just even of some kind and then again opportunities the farest service there
Also one other theme in all this is one one thing that's frustrating me about ecology
And it still does a lot is it's hard to measure things precisely
you know, it's
And to somebody a lot of scientists they want to get to the bottom of things
They don't want to have a conclusion that says well, maybe this can be that can be this
We have data we have models, you know works this way, and that's just a nature of the beast
And in genetics you tend to get much closer to hard answers
And that was that was appealing to me
And then all the genetic technology that was coming along continues to just you know
my whole career
The field of genetics is exploded five times
Was attractive, you know, first it was enzymes and first it was turquinoids
And the chemistry thereof and the gas chromatographs
And that was these enzymes you were doing to look at genetic variation in a way that we never did
And then it was DNA and then it was genomics
So doing DNA on a massive scale
And then genetic engineering
So it's been this progression of incredibly powerful
And intellectually exciting and potentially very important technologies
So that's also pulled me out of ecology some
These technologies have been used in ecology quite a lot
But it's taken a long time to get there
Sounds like it was a fairly seamless transition to Berkeley for you
Well yeah, you know, I'd been there before and you know, I knew the place
And I loved it, you know, I just loved being in Berkeley
Those five years I was there
It was a great environment for a young person
And it's definitely a very
Artificial environment
And the reason I say that as one of my memories from there is
I think the first year we were there
This would be 1980
I hope I have the story right
Reagan was running against
I think it was Jimmy Carter
Maybe for Carter's second term or something like that
And he could be in Berkeley and think that Carter was a shoe in
And of course, I think you won no state but Massachusetts or something like that
And, you know, so again, you're in this little bubble of Berkeley
And you know, everything's very progressive
You know, realize where the country's at
And it's kind of sad to start a little bit this last election
Yeah
Tell me a bit more about this time I you progressed through your PhD years
Yeah, the PhD in Berkeley was really a good for me
I really enjoyed Cal Berkeley a lot
It had a lot of sort of what I was mentioning about
Yeah, the environmental stuff, the foam and the science
And also a lot still a lot of the traditional stuff
Some of the older economists and civil culture
It's very, very famous
People, Hank Fox, John Zavnuska
My main mentor at Berkeley, Bill Libby
Very charismatic guy
Very much
Really in the mold that I've taken on a micro
I've kind of been a
spokesperson, if you will, for the use of genetic engineering
as a technology in forestry
Which is a difficult thing
And it's difficult, biologically, it's difficult
Socially, a lot of the incredible power of environmental groups
around the world that's exploded during my life
They're almost all opposed to either unilateral or extremely negative
So, Bill was kind of
He was a proponent of cloning in forestry
So, you know, you got to a wild forest
Now, every tree is a unique genotype
Like humans mostly are
With the exception of the occasional identical swim
And he said, well, what if you could pick the very most productive one
Out of this mass of variation
You know, not just one
But the top 10, the top 100 for production purposes
For wild forests, you'll maintain all the diversity you possibly can
But for production forests
If we could clone it, the benefits would be
Cloned them, the benefits would be huge
And so he argued that his whole career
And had some success, I mean, some of it was used
But he was very much pushing against the tide at that point
So the industry was very traditional
And then the environmental tide as well
So, I've said in a sense, following in its footsteps
Which is interesting, you know
Being a good biologist, I think
But being also outspoken on some of these policy issues
And using sort of innovative, new, socially novel genetic technology
Me and the GMO area, and then the cloning area
So anyway, you know, he was a very outspoken guy
And so he was very influential to me
But the whole, the whole intellectual environment of Berkeley
Was very stimulating
I T-8 in forest policy
So, you know, as a young scientist, I would say
Have a limited notion of how policies are made
And how laws are passed, and what they mean
They just figure, you know, you learn how it works in nature
And then, you do it smarter and better
And the notion that there's all these layers of rules and regs
And perceptions, invested interests
You know, we're just kind of naive
I mean, it's just that simple
And so, being at Berkeley was a time
Where I really sort of got my eyes opened up
You know, taking and teaching about forest policy
Just, you know, I realize that
You know, scientists really want to change the world
They really need to be out there
They can't be naive in their labs
In their little fields
I think they have to be out there interacting with society
And, you know, I think I've done some of that
Not as much as some of my colleagues
But, you know, and I think today
You see a lot of activity on campuses
And that scientists need to do it even more
We have this March on Science
March 4 science coming up
In April and I think it's science to say
You know, it's just not going to be okay to be quiet
You have to get out there
And, but speaking for science is also
I'm rambling here a bit
But speaking for science is also really complicated
The scientists are all biased and ideological
Like everybody else
So, it's a really messy thing
Your dissertation was on storage next size, that correct?
It was, yeah
It was back in those days
They had these enzyme technologies
Called isosigns or allosigns
So, it turns out that
You know, you have thousands of proteins in your body
Trees due to
And due to genetic variation
The forms of those proteins vary
They just do what they do
But they do it a little bit differently
And so, back in the 60s, 70s, 80s
Scientists realize that instead of
Measuring genetic variation
See, based on variation and height
Of people like ourselves
That are influenced by the environment
How you have will you
As well as your DNA
You could look right at
The products of DNA in these proteins
We weren't able to look at DNA in self yet
So, that whole allosign
Genetic diversity
Technology was very, very big for 30 years
And that's my thesis
It was about trying to see
If you could look at the amount of
Genetic polymorphism
Variability in these enzymes
And trees, and could you predict their productivity
Are trees that have a greater diversity of enzymes
Are they more productive and a natural environment
Using the materials that are available to me
That was the question that I tried to answer
And I had some success
In the sense that I got some publications out about it
In good journals
But by no means that I resolve it at that level
And I have that question actually
Bigger question in science
Still continues
So, you finished up at Cal in 1985
And then you
Variety OSU, how did that come about
Yeah, that was an amazing thing
So, I did this thesis
That was really about genetic polymorphism
Whether it predicts productivity
And environmental stress tolerance
Was another element of it
And it had experimental plantations
But it wasn't really about production
It wasn't about biotechnology
By any, in any means
That wasn't called biotechnology
We didn't have that word really back then
And back at the time
In the 80s when I was at Cal
The field of biotech, what came to be called biotechnology
So, recombinant DNA
Cutting and splicing genes
Was starting
It had started in bacteria a few years earlier
And scientists were beginning to use its study diseases
The study cancer
To study human pathogens of various sorts
And then it started percolating into plants
Where people use it, we're using it the same way
And then scientists figured out
How they could transfer genes from one organism to another
So they could do sort of what people have done in bacteria years earlier
They could now do an implant
So the possibility of genetic engineering plants
For enhanced traits, suddenly was there
And everybody was talking about it
And I remember I think it was 84
A year before I graduated
My mentor, Tom Lettingley
I mentioned from Yale, it went to Berkeley
Health of big conference
How should we be using biotechnologies and forestry
What are the opportunities, what are the constraints
And I'm watching this
And I'm not a biotechnologist
I didn't really know what DNA was per se
Apart from
And suddenly it's like this is the next big thing
It's coming at us
And then the year 84, 85, depending on exactly how you dated
The first genetic engineer plant was created
And then two years later, the first genetic engineer tree up offer tree
That I've actually continued to work on
Most of them, my career was created
And the forest service was working on it
Just seemed like this is just a big, a big wonderful thing
And a big scientific technological challenge
And so I remember when this job came open at Oregon State
I was, you know, somewhere around December or so of 84
Maybe January of 85
And I remember seeing it, someone pointed out to me
The, you know, so we've always had Oregon State
We've always had really strong forest genetics
It was a sub-discipline of forest science
And we've been strong in, at OSU, we've been strong in the forest service
Right across the parking lot
And so we had a geneticist, Kim Chang
Who was retiring
And so they said, well, what should we do?
Should we hire another Kim Chang?
Kim worked on psychology
Meaning, chromosome level
Genetic biology of trees, Douglas Farr
Or should we start going down deeper?
Just go down to the DNA level
That's where the science is going
And it's all this, all this foaming going on
And so we said, we're gonna, we're gonna take a risk and hire a biotechnologist
And I don't think any of the forestry school had done so yet
But about that time there were two or three that did it
So I don't remember if it was us
Or it was C-State
Or who was actually number one
But we were right there
Instead of taking this risk really
To invest in this new area
And so at that point there
There were not a cadre of forest biotechnology
PhDs and postdocs around
Because the field didn't exist
There were a couple
Just starting who had done work and
You know other species
Barley a colleague of mine, Dave Neil
And I know what you grabbed, very great scientist
Had done a postdoc and barley
Learning some of that stuff
But it wasn't trees
These were some of my competitors and for this job
Anyway, so I asked my mentors
I just said, you know, what's with this biotechnology thing
Is this like flash in the pan?
Is it, you know
Should I apply for this job?
I don't have back, and I said, yeah, you should apply for it
You know, yours
Yours qualified as anybody
Get in how young this field is
And then I did
I went on this crash course
Of learning about biotechnology
And so I
You know, I applied
And they basically hired me
On the notion that I had
You know, potential to grow with the field
And you know, I didn't say
I just like that turned out to be a pretty good
Pretty good guess
And so that's how it started
I really, this is really a new venture for me
Is a new venture for
Forestry and OSU
And you know, it's had a number of turns
That no one predicted
But it's from the science point of view
From a career
Developmental point of view
It's, you know, been very successful
Yeah, sounds like a nice piece of
Strategic thinking or visionary thinking
I think so
Yeah, I think they knew they were doing that
They didn't really know where it was going to go
And I got here
You know, and I said, so what do you want me to do?
I said, I don't know
Well, what's biotechnology?
Figure it out
And do it
And actually the first five, seven years
I realized that genetic engineering was not really
You know, it had been done once
In one place
A tree was engineered
But it wasn't ready to go
So what can I do
And what I realized I could do
And I was also very successful
And made a name for myself
For early was I could
Use these DNA techniques
To figure out
The evolution of some of our major tree species
I think I had the most important paper
At that time
On pines and how they evolved
I had the most important paper
At that time, on Douglass Fur
And it's relatives and where it came from
And relationship to all its relatives
Around the Pacific, where I'm in the on
So there's a lot of insights that
You know, when you get to the DNA level
When you get an insight about
Relationships and evolution
They're often very, very strong
This is this thing, this precision
You get when you sequence
Or analyze DNA into that level
Suddenly people say, well, it's not just his opinion
About whether the size of the cones
Or the thickness of the barks
And the most important trait
It's this, you know, sort of random look at the DNA
And it just shouts at you
Which trees are most related to which
And who the common ancestor is
And so
What I did the first five or seven years
I did a lot of this genetic evolutionary analysis
Disappear really high quality science
And the people at OSU
Even though
My dean department had what a love to see me
Like
Help the forest industry right then
And they said, this is the right thing to be doing right now
And so was, you know
They did have a very open mind about it
But then eventually
And perhaps not getting ahead of myself
But I'll mention briefly
What happened in Oregon and in Northwest
Is people started worrying about sources of wood and pulp
Because we had the spotted allowars
We had rising environmentalism
And people were afraid there wouldn't be enough wood
So they started investing
And the Department of Energy made major investments
And growing these popular trees and plantations
Like the ones along I-84
That we talked about
Now those are products of that
And so people started doing series for search
And that was a big project at University of Washington on that
And I realized that I had the expertise
That was developed to add a genetic engineering element to it
And that started early 90s, late 80s, early 90s
And I started working with the industries
And developed an industry cooperative
Consortium basically a public-private partnership
And our college of forestry has a bunch of those
And still does
Where they provide money
Not a lot of money
But enough to sort of help guide it toward things of interest to them
And then we at the University
So use our resources and go out and go grant dollars
To sort of make good science of relevance happen
And working in poplars
I mentioned the first tree that was engineered was a poplar
Suddenly people are thinking about growing poplars
On a major scale in Oregon and in the Northwest
Let's use this technology to do it even better
And so a lot of my career has been
Instead of I took that step
For this consortium started working in poplars and genetic engineering
And I quickly got involved also in some of the social and legal issues of it
Like I said earlier, those are big
And they continue to be big
So that was the reason I made that shift early in my career at OSU
Into the genetic engineering per se
And also helping to deal with the social elements
Working with industries, forest industries, biotech industries
And so that's been kind of the big middle
of my career and in some continues
What is it about poplars that make most attractive to this work?
You know, they're much better from a science point of view
They're much better model organisms
So everything about Douglas Fur and Pine, you can imagine
When it comes to doing genetic manipulation is hard
I was terpenized, I mentioned early, well, they mess up
You're getting your DNA out of analyzing it
People have sort of got it got over it these days
But it's just one other thing
The genomes are huge
In poplars, we figured out pretty early on
In fact, the number one tree, how to insert a gene
Or modify a gene and then grow the progeny
And see how that one gene affects them
And in the conifer, that's still incredibly difficult to do
Very expensive and very difficult
So something about them makes them easier to engineer
They're genomes are small, they grow faster
It's very powerful in genetics
When you make a genetic change
Or you have a genetic variant of interest
To make copies of it
Just for replication
So you have high quality science
Poplars in nature
Cognum cells all the time
That's you know, these astins
You may have read about these grows of astins
There are kinds of poplars can cover
Many many acres in one single genotype
That doesn't happen much in conifers
So they're easy to make copies of
So there's a bunch of reasons
Easy to transform, small genome, easy to make copies of
Faster growing
That make them very good genetic models
And then also you know
The industry was already looking at making hybrids
Between different species to increase productivity
They were already cloning them for plantations
And so the genetics was very intense
And then adding genetic engineering
As another kind of genetics made sense
Because you go in
The industry already brought it in science
It's already brought it to this level
Let's take that level further
When you look at Douglas Ferr or
Or Pines
Even today
The genetics is primitive
You know, compared to any crop species
Compared to poplars
And so it's much higher to say
Genetic engineering is what we need to do now
We're still sort of in the neolithic
With breeding
So it doesn't make as much sense
The accomplish it does
So you have all these reasons
The biology as well as the state of breeding
And then also if you're making a particular product
With poplars like
Or particular kinds of wood or biofuels
You can optimize it much more
And that's how the industry came about
Whereas in the sort of generalized forestry
We're making all kinds of things
And there are all kinds of conditions
We don't control the environment as much as grown on it
You know, steep hillsides
And poppers
It's more agricultural
In fact, they're
Regulated as agricultural crops
By Oregon and Washington
And so everything about the social and biological environment
Made it
Sensible to consider trying to add
In genetic engineering as an exgenetic technology
Backing up just a hair
I'm interested in collecting a little bit of institutional knowledge
Yeah
At the university and of the college
What do you remember about your early impressions
Of OSU and of the college of forestry
You know, the things that stand out over all these years
Dean Stoltenberg who hired me
And
Successor George Brown
Just this incredible sense of
You know, go out there and make an impact
Serve the state, serve the nation, serve
Just this incredible ethic of service
You know, I came out of
I came in here still somewhat young
Still very much wanting to do science
And wanting to survive also in academia
I was very nervous
You know, I'm going to be able to get tenure
And you know, and it's just
And they really wanted much more
They weren't interested so much
I'm going to survive and get my next grant
But what am I going to do to change the world for the better
Well, how am I going to
And also they had a sense of how am I going to serve
The Oregon industry better
And make Oregon more productive
And economically more vital
So I just felt that
I felt the pressure of it
But I also felt that it was wholesome and real
And good
And so that was another reason
For the transition to popular
As I mentioned, I did this
Genetic work early on
On the evolutionary relationships
At different species
That was a great way to use biotech methods
To advance science
But it wasn't really going to advance
Oregon far sure
And accepting a very fundamental level
And so when poplars came along
And in fact, I could use genetic engineering
I could do great science
And it can have an impact on the industry
And on society
Maybe tomorrow
If we can really grow trees
You know, 10-20% better by using genetic engineering methods
And we can do it in poplars in my lab
And get it out there
You know, that's exciting
That conjunction of application
And you know, one thing that we've worked on too for many years
That tied into my environmental background
Is, you know, it was pretty obvious to me
That
Genetic engineering trees
Poplars
We're going to be controversial for variety of reasons
We've already seen it in agriculture and medicine
And so it's not like society is going to just say
Rarararala, let's have more of it
They're going to say, I don't like this
Or they're going to say
Who controls it
And so on and so forth
And how should be regulated
What should the role of the EPA be
And should be really have very strict regulations
So you know, it was obvious to me that was all going to happen
And what's happening
And the biggest
Issue that science can deal with about that
Is
So release of propagules into natural environments
So I think cognitively you cross a line
When you say we're going to genetic engineer something
Then you're really saying that humans are really taking control of this organism
And changing it to their needs
Of course we do that with conventional breeding
I know all of our crops
Corn, whatever it is
Are looking at nothing like their wild relatives
And we've made that cognitive leap
But I think now we're even more
I'll conjure that than we used to be
Genetic engineering
Because it's an unnatural
Mostly unnatural technique
It does happen in nature but not commonly
You cross this cognitive line
Where it was obvious to me that people are not going to
Well people might say, well I'll accept
In these intensive popular plantations
That look nothing like a natural
That genetic engineering can have a place
But I don't want the pollen and seeds spreading out into wild riparian
Cottonwood areas
Where really what we value is biodiversity
And all the ecosystem functions
That's going to be a problem
And indeed it is
So we said you know so we need to
For those plantations trees
We need to shut down flower
We think trees grow faster as a result
But the main thing is that
Even though poppers do vegetative
We spread a little bit
We can manage that
But we can't manage pollen
Floating miles and miles in there
And so another exciting thing was
In addition to developing the gene transfer methods
And working with industries to test things
We said we're going to develop the genetic containment technology
So society accepts it
I mean we continue to make that our focus all these years
And that really tied into my sort of environmental consciousness coming in
Let's use advanced technology but let's do it right
And so that's probably what I'm most known for around the world
Is developing this containment technology
And putting it into practice
To take a long time
You know the science takes a while
Getting the genes in
And then if you're studying flowering
You have to wait years
Because trees don't flower right away
So what really is
I didn't realize there's so much at the time
When I made that decision in the early 90s
I was committing to two or three decades of
Experiments and that's what's happened
You know, there's still going on
There's still on the field outside for balance
At what point did you start to receive some pushback
From various outside entities
Pretty much from the get-go
You know in the beginning there really has been
And I don't know if anybody's measured it
I'm sure actually that's what they haven't
I should probably go find the papers
What they've done
But I used to mock some of the media coverage
And including OSU's own public relations
That here's biotechnology
It's the answer to all our problems
It's going to feed the world
It's going to revolutionize
We're going to make square trees
That you know, just go right into the boards
You know, it's all this crazy stuff
That I knew was not going to have
That I'm not going to happen in my lifetime
So it was hyped
And society kind of, that's where they were sort of giddy about it
And then over, I think it was the late 90s
When various things happened
In agricultural biotechnology
Where then the media coverage became pretty negative
And big environmental groups
Like green peas with hundreds of millions of dollars of funds
Essentially environmental corporations
Decided they were against all of it everywhere
Whether you were making, you know,
Or fight them in aid to deal with blindness
Whether you're trying to make tree
They were against all of it
It was an ideological thing
And so probably because organizations like that
With a lot of power and money changed
Things shifted
Things became much more negative
And then in the, again, in the later 90s
When you started to see a lot of vandalism
First in agricultural biotechnology
Then in forestry
And so in 2001 was a big year
Here at Oregon State in Corvallis
We had vandalism
Somebody came in during the middle of the night
In Corvallis
And cut through a wire fence
And damaged it at a thousand trees
It was at night
And you can't tell the ones that are genetically
And engineering for ones that aren't
So most of them
They actually didn't get what they wanted to
But, you know, it was indication of just the intensity of the issue
That I think was in March
And then in June
There was arson
Against the collaborative of mine at the University of Washington
His building was almost completely burned down
Collaborating industry
And clats can I had a million dollars
And farm equipment damaged
So it really ramped up
And it really got intense
I was the chair of an international
Society for tree biotechnology
We were having a meeting in Oxford
In, I guess it was 1999
A couple of years earlier
And the one
The one field trial of the genetic engineering tree in England
Was vandalized
The evening of our international scientific conference
And so all these things
You know, told me that
Holy cow
Society's not with us
And then in Europe in particular
Which was sort of finally reacting against Lonsanto
And bringing in
You know, genetic engineering
Soybeans
As animal feed into the country
And blockating them and all that
When these trees were damaged
Outside of Oxford
The
And these trees were trees that had
Without going into the technical details
They were engineered to be easier to pulp
Meaning take less energy, less chemicals
To produce the same amount of pulp
So it's something that we have thought of scientists
The environmentalists were going to love
And that we have strong support for
But no
The bigger narrative in society really dominated that
So when these trees were destroyed
The science about what we were doing was irrelevant
And the
The storyline and the major media
The Guardian and others
Was Monsanto now
You know, they're wreak havoc
And the foods apply
And now they're going to wreak havoc and are forest
And we are all like holy cow
Well, you know, what are these guys?
Smoking
But you know, that's how big
Then the
Social narrative
Is about genetic engineering and GMOs
The details of the science really don't matter much
And that's a hard thing to remember
But anyway, so, you know, 1999-2001
Also in 2001, we had 9-11 in the United States
And the government called eco-terrorist terrorists
And they pursued them the same way as they pursued people
Who are bombing the World Trade Center
And so that kind of stuff stopped
The guys who did the stuff in Oregon and Washington
Were mostly cotton, but in jail
And in Europe, they continued
In the US, it stopped
But that was, you know, a big marker
That things were just crazy out of hand
But society's reaction continued to ramp up after that
And, you know, one of the conditions we have today
Is that Greenpeace and others who are very against this stuff
Have created conditions
Where forest industries really can't use genetic engineering
Very
The their own certification organizations
Don't allow it
Even in research
So the field trials, the collaborative work I dealt with industry years ago
Doesn't happen anymore
Because, or happens outside of
The Northwest in very special conditions
Because the social conditions have become so hostile
You know, just like you
Just like in organic food
You can't have any GMO in it no matter what
Even though scientists will say
There's good uses of it
In addition to the ones that are questionable
It's an all or nothing thing
And that's where society's at with forestry uses right now
And one of the things I've done in my career is try to argue that
We need research
To find out what are the good uses
What are the not so good uses
How we can make
And not so good use
And make it good
You know, and
That kind of
That's really not gone anywhere
Even though I've tried
To sort of
What I would consider to have a more middle
And more reasonable science-based agenda
The environment for community
The marketing
Arm of it in particular
Feels like this is the way they have to be
To get the consumers to buy their products
To charge more for it
And maybe do the right thing on their view
So it's
It's become a hostile world
I'm really
I'll be able to finish my career
Using this technology
But by and large
In forestry around the world
The amount of interest in genetic engineering
As I'm death that is really gone
It's not zero
But it's really gone way down
The social pushback
It's been
Bigger than anybody could have imagined
So, how have you
Been able to navigate that
Or how have you
Have an effort to adapt
Or compromise
Yeah
You know, it's a reality
And you know, it's important to recognize
It's sort of a
Twelve steps thing
Recognize what you can change
And once you can
And so I, you know,
I've written a bunch of papers about how
What a smarter way would be
To regulate
What a smarter way to be
To market it
I had a paper in Science Magazine last year
I've been able to publish
In the very best journals
Putting forward ideas of
Collaborative lawyers and economists
You know, to get the social stuff
Right
You know, being on
I'm a biologist
But, you know
There's a larger
Larger forces
Larger social economic forces
You know, big companies
Profit from
You know, avoiding GMOs
They're not going to stop doing it
You know, it's not
Not just philosophical, it's a huge
Profit margin to saying
You're cleaner than now
I mean, I call it greenwashing
But it's everywhere in the marketplace
Now, I can't buy a loaf of bread
That I want without a no GMO seal
Even though I'd like to avoid it
Because I know it's meaningless
So that's, you know, it's a bigger thing
So what are you doing that, man?
It's from my point of view
You know, we had at OSU
We had an outreach and biotechnology program
Mainly funded to the College of Ag
Probably funded through Forestry
That I was the chair of
The director of for about eight years
It was kind of a soft program
It used to be something that was a hard program
An extension
And instead of got softer over the years
But we did it
We had a website
And we hosted 40 public lectures
We got amazing scientists
And all over the coming
And talked to the public
In Corralis about all these issues
So that was one way that I thought
I could sort of really help change society
Or make society smarter about this
And I think it was super successful
But I think OSU
The College of Agriculture has sort of tired
Over this
And there's only so much science can do
And so they've sort of backed away
They don't want to alienate
They're more organic elements
They're non-NKGMO
And so most universities
Not all of them, but some large majority have said
This is bigger than we can deal with
Our state funds are being cut
We'd rather have somebody use breeding berries
Than nobody breeding berries
And have somebody fighting this
This way wave of anti-biotechnology
Because it's very complicated
It is, you know, if you do responsible outreach about it
It's not just rar-ar-ah
It's here is the trade-offs
Here's the pros in the cons and the center
So it's a complicated story
So anyway, from my own point of view
I've sort of fought
Road scientific papers
Talk to regulators
I still get three or four or five talks a year
I've talked at the public library
And sound to the environmental educators
Consortium up there a few weeks ago
So I still do things occasionally
But the basic I've said
You know I could do research
To advance the science and the technology
And when society is ready
If they're ever ready, it'll be there
And so that's where I put 95% of my energies
Is doing the science
And it's hard, one thing
Conditions are sufficiently adverse
In both Europe and the United States
For applied biotechnology in the public sector
That it's very hard to go to a USDA
Or department of energy, grandpa
And say I have an idea
For a better genetic engineer trade
We're going to tweak this and that
And then they're going to say
Well, it's a GMO right
So it's going to be really hard to get regulatory approval
Companies are going to have trouble growing it
So we're not going to fund that
And that's happened the last 15 years
It's very hard
But the one kind of funding
You can still get a little bit of
Is if you want to say
Well, we need better safety technology
We need to not worry so much about getting better trees
But getting safer trees
And so that's really that
Middle niche has allowed me to
To continue doing the research I do on genetic containment
And so forth
And so that's one of the ways
I've been able to keep doing
What I believe is interesting and important
Getting the science done
Testing it in the field
To me it's very important
Not just that I do laboratory work
Because you need to go out
Into a real-the-real world
Most laboratory ideas don't actually work
Because the world is complicated
And so I have stuff out
I have 10 acres growing in Carvalis now
That are testing ideas from the field
From the laboratory
At any rate
But it's this safety orientation
That's allowed me to keep
Productive, keep doing good science
Even though the social
Millio is extremely adverse
And funding is very hard to get
So the work on biode safety
And the sterile nursery plants
Has almost been a survival strategy in your point
Exactly, yeah
And it's survival
But it's also something I said
I'm interested in
And when I started that construction
Started working on poppers I said
We need to figure out containment
And so I'm still doing that
And luckily that hasn't dried up
You know
You know, it could anytime
But it hasn't so far
And I do work that
Is state of the art
It's competitive
Throughout science and throughout agriculture
So these are the panel that funds this
It's mainly a USDA panel
Called biotechnology risk assessment
That won the ARS
Thing that you just mentioned
Was a separate thing related to it
But that's funding all of agriculture
So we have to be doing work on trees
That is competitive with the very best work in corn
And that's hard
Because they have a lot more money
And there are a lot more advanced genetics
But I'm proud that I've been able to do that
I can compete with those guys
Because the science we do is just as good
If I didn't dug the store
I probably couldn't
But I can do it in public
Something else for you
Yeah
That caught my was
The project on carbon sequestration
Using popper trees
Yeah
About that
Well, you know
You know, it's interesting
It's a very
If you decide you're going to grow trees
Seriously for some purpose
Meaning they're going to have a dominant dedicated use
What you what nature gives you
Is okay
And you can tweak it further
But often you want something very different
And so
People do ecological modeling
Started saying
Well, you know, if we produced trees
That had more roots
And less stem
Which is contrary to what people do in forestry
They tend to want the fastest growing tallest tree
I said no, maybe we don't want the tallest one
Maybe we want the fattest one with lots of roots
And the roots will add to the carbon and the soil
And decay much slower
And stem material would
Maybe
Maybe we can even make the roots
So they decay more slowly
Enhance the amount of
Turpen lines and phonolics
These compounds that slow down
Decomposition so the carbon
Stays around in the soil longer
So it's those ideas that we could change
The allocation between tops and bottoms
And change the chemistry of roots
That would promote carbon sequestration
That was the idea
We also thought
If we had a tree that has more roots
It'll survive great stresses
It'll bioremediate soils better
We also have a problem in industry
That sometimes we can select the fastest growing trees
And this has happened in the Northwest with Poplar
As they blow down
We get these giant windstorms every now and then
And they just blow over
And so
And then also we have an agriculture
The green revolution
Which is not a biotech GMO thing
But it's a bunch of technologies
Starting in about the 1960s
The key one is a scientist figured out
That we don't want taller wheat
We don't want taller rice
When you just select for productivity
Everything gets taller
And then when you have a storm
They blow over their lodge
And you probably see this around Pendleton
That happens occasionally
And then the crop is lost at rots
The quality is caused
So what the scientists did is
They found a dwarfism gene
Semi-dwarfism
That keeps the wheat instead of being
In a way over your head
It keeps it about here
And mostly we see around Oregon is like that
But that's a particular gene
brought in from an Asian variety
That constrains it from getting taller
So it gets more root
So it gets more seeds on it
And it doesn't launch
So it was also that thinking
That maybe we can sequester more carbon
Have a tree that's more drought taller
And bioremediates better
By having them be shorter
And I'm not talking about three feet tall
This is a tree
So instead of 100 feet
You might be 60 feet
Whatever
Between slow it down
And change
The distribution
And the quality of the biomass
And so that's what that project was about
Trying to tweak these trees
For these particular goals
And we were successful at it
We did, you know
And some of the genes we tested were genes
From the green revolution we
And because the mechanisms
Are very fundamental
They work quite well
And so we were able to get shorter trees
With more roots
And uh
But was anybody going to use them?
No
Because they're a GMO
And because they're
It would change the industry
Industry doesn't work that way
Breeding would have to be radically different
We'd have to get a GMO
Probably into the breeding program
Because one of the things you're doing
Is your
Creating trees that are smaller
Can grow as fast
While in nature
Those trees die
Right, because they can't get light
So um
You'd have to change
The whole way you breed trees
And evaluate them
And anyway
It would be very disruptive to the industry
But with the GMO element
Of it it was a non-starter
So we did the work
It was successful
And you know
There it is
The science is done
Does somebody ever want to pick it up?
You know, I don't know
Um
But that's what that was about
In short of it
Yeah
And that was a
Project that had an association with Sungrant
Is that correct?
That's right
Yeah
That was a
Department of Energy, USDA funded
There was a couple of them
The biggest funding we got
Was from the
Biofuels section of the Department of Energy
That was a big
And then we had some supplementary funding from other places
We've also got funding from the Sungrant
A couple other places
On trying to make a tree
That would have some
Value-boat co-products
So one of the problems with growing bioenergy
Is that energy is cheap in the world
Unless we tax fossil fuels
Really aggressively
Which we're not
Almost anywhere
As aggressively as it probably should be
They're not competitive
So how do you make them more competitive
One of the ways is to engineer
In some product
That is high value
A new biochemical
That would be have some other higher use in industry
So we've tried to get trees that produce bioplastics
Things that you can use
And we're already using the similar versions
From bacteria
Of these cops that decompose
That you can put in the compost
We tried to make the same kind of thing
Of polymer trees
And we did it
But we couldn't make an after-make it economic
So we really need a major engine
Euring leap to make that work
And so
We're just no funding for it
But you know
But it's also a hard problem
But that's what
That's what one of the Sungrant projects
Was about
Was trying to figure out how to make those biofuels
And we collaborated with companies
That were doing it in different crops
And it's a hard problem
And we still
I thought a student
Who's sort of working on an element of it
But it's
It would require a pretty serious effort
Yeah
Has any of your work intersected
With the cross-laminated
Products at all?
Only that the
No, the short answers
No
I was at a conference
The
Panco Foundation
Is this
Forestry Foundation
Funded by this
I assume which guy who really wants to infuse
Advanced engineering technology of all kinds
To make better wood products
Including the laminated products
For Oregon and for the industry
And he's
You know why aren't we doing genetic engineering
He's looking at all the amazing things
In engineering
You know
In the traditional sense
Why not genetic engineering
And I went to this conference
With other engineers
And I told them
It's the broader social element
And it's also that the industry is not ready for it
Because we're still
Sort of in the Neolithic breeding wise
And so it would just be like
Trying to teach a baby to run before
It's able to walk
It just didn't make sense
He didn't want to hear that
But that's that's the reality of it
You know so it could be done
And you know if we
But before we did that for example
If you're going to have the precision of genetic engineering
To try to
Get the fibers to set up
Be bonded in a way that would be better for CLT
Or glue better
Whatever it might be
The first thing you don't want to do
Is just homogenize the wood
So you know you
So as an engineer you want to know
It's going to be a certain thing
And then you can tweak it right
And right now in our forest
The variability in wood properties is incredible
So you first want to be able
To probably clone trees
And the problem with that
Is that it's not affordable
In the industry right now
So unless you get to that
That's again
You know
Crawl walk before you run
We're not going to get there
So I also told them that
The industry until we can get to those barriers
We're not ready for it
And that's a matter of economics
And probably also social acceptability
Would it be okay to have clone
Duggles for all over the landscape?
I don't know
What was the Sierra Club saying?
They probably heed the idea
So you know
So industry
But due to economics
Plus concern
It's just not happening
Yeah
Tell me about the Leopold leadership
Fellowship program
I think a guy that was something
And fairly important to you
Yeah that really is
That's a great thing
And it resonates today
So
Jane Leopcanko at OSU
Standard Professor
You know President of Triple White House
National Academy member
You know amazing scientist and person
She and some colleagues
Scientists don't
Have the skills
And the network to communicate
With the media and decision-makers
Like they need to
You know
Her interest was in getting
More environmental science
And science in general
Into policy
You know and most politicians
Don't have science backgrounds
Almost none of them do
And so you need to talk their language
You need to know
You know how the
How decisions are made
And you need to know
How to talk to the media
You know how to talk to science journalists
Non-science journalists
So they she created this program
It was funded by various foundations
Over the years
It's still centered at Stanford
An organization at Stanford
It still goes on
And they train cohorts
Of something like
Twini
Or so
Leading
Environmental scientists
People sort of in a make career
Who you can see
Have been very successful
And are going to make an impact
And are called
To
To speak to the world
To change the world
Very much like who I was growing up
And who I still am
And so you apply
You say what you do
You look at your publication record
Your passions
Your skills
And so I was one
I think I may be the only
person who would call
Themself a biotechnologist
In that program
It's mostly ecologists
Few lawyers involved
We'll be conunders
But it's been pretty much
Very strongly environmental people
People not so much working
On the
The
Technology side of it
But anyway
This
This group has been going on now
I'm going to guess 20 years
Something like that
But they have these cohorts
Of
Scientists who come through
And a lot of them are now
You know very well established in the field
And there's a network of them
And they communicate
And they collaborate
And they try to organize action
Or let us to the editor
And conferences
So particularly now
And you know with all the things going on
On the CHOP administration
It's kind of been
You know come back to life
And where they're really trying to do things
And so far
And so anyway
That's I'm part of that organization
And you know I love to see information
They share about
How to be more effective
What do you do now as a scientist
What's the right thing to do
There's a discussion going on
About whether it's
Good or bad
To engage in the March for science
Next month
Is that politicizing science more
Making us more
Of a special interest group
Versus you know
Arbitives of truth
Or not
Or we have to
And so that's an example
Of how that network helps
People think
Distribute information
And so it's very nice
You know like I said
I'm a
Kind of an outsider in it
And I kind of feel like
When it comes to GMO
Those in biotechnology
And agriculture
Probably the majority of them are
A negative on it
You know
And I'm kind of a lone wolf there
And saying
And this is powerful
We just have to use it right
So uh
I know
So I'm
I'm buzzing that
And it's important to me
But it's also a network
Of environmental scientists
That are mostly
I'm not interested in the kind of stuff
That I do
So
Anyway there it is
I'm not
Superactive
And by any means
Probably because as I said
It doesn't
It's kind of a little bit to the
To the left
Whatever it is of
Where I'm at in terms of using technology
In the world
Can you talk a bit more about GMOs
With respect to food
That's obviously a big
Big issue for people
Yeah, you know
I followed that
Pretty intensive
Teacher batter at OSU
I've been doing that
I had this outreach program
It's very hot
And very political
And
You know I think one thing
That's really clear
Is that it's
Mostly not about the science
I think the people who
Are very against GMOs
Want to make it about
Very dangerous
Inadequately studied science
And I just think
For them that's a tool
Attacked it
I think
The people in the know
No better
Than that
So but there's you know
There's there's
Issues of intensive
Probably the biggest issue
Is industrial agriculture in general
You know on it's
Incredible benefits and incredible harms
You know probably plowing
Is the most damaging thing
We do the whole planning
But it's not just industrial agriculture
The plows it's
Organic agriculture
And everybody else
And they often do it more
So you know
And then you have
Use of agricultural chemicals
Which are an incredible energy
Saver and productivity
And answer
But they can be used
With they can harm things
You know the Rachel Carson
And Silent Spring helped show that for DDT
And so now we're in a whole different era
Than we were back then
Where things are
Intensively regulated and monitored
And many bad things have been taken off markets
And you know at least in the western world
And to get a chemical approved
You know it takes
I think hundreds of millions of dollars
Of tests and studies
And the labels that are restricted to use
And so forth
So there's a lot of safeguards
Built into the system we didn't have
Back in the in the old days
But it's a good enough
Now it's not going to be perfect
We're going to make mistakes
So how do you think about chemicals used in agriculture
And you have systems like
The organic certification system
That's a
It won't use any
Except actually for quite a long list of exceptions
If you read the details
But
So that's another element
And the
The major GMO crops now
Use chemicals
Directly and directly
They use chemicals in the form of
Promoting herbicides
By being herbicide resistant
They use chemicals in the sense of
Isolating a pesticide
From a bacterium
And putting it into plants
And this pesticide is something called
BT
Is one that's widely used in organic agriculture
So it's very very very safe
And I've spliced it into a plant
Well now it's supposed to be very unsafe
So you know there is all
But anyway, but it involves
Things like chemicals and it involves
Intensive EPA regulation
And the more you regulate
Doesn't mean
That people feel better about it
It means it actually shines a big spotlight on it
And so
It's just extremely messy
Both from a society and so on
And of course
The science continues to grow
And it invades
There's new stuff
All the time
So how much regulation
Just impedes public benefits
And impedes economic development
Versus protects
The public and the environment
And getting that right is crucial
And you know
And by no means
A supporter of the current
Presidential Administration
And the particular individual
But the issue of how much regulation is too much
Is a really hard technical one
And the sound bites you get
And all the news media are generally misleading and wrong
But in the area of biotech
And I've written a lot
I think the regulations are
Totally out of control
There are some kinds of biotech
That should be intensively regulated
Probably more than we have now
Another kind is really there's
There's a good record
That there's no regulation needed at all
Zero
We have this single gene editing
The new technology
From modifying
The natural DNA there
To for straining reason
Which is what breeding does
But now we do it with science and precision
That's probably going to be
Regulated
Certainly in Europe
Like it's taking the gene
From a far away species
It's from my plenty
Just crazy
This is the CRISPR technique
Yeah
But that's kind of
And you know that's a big source of controversy right now
The USDA pedaled a proposal
To not regulate some parts of that
Which I think is you know
Innovative and forward looking
I don't know what's going to happen
Under the current administration
In Europe it's very likely to go that way
Either way the organic people
Are going to
I've already said I'm record
They will not accept it
So um
You know it's just
An ugly messy area
Frankly
And it's
Rife was traded off
So I just gave a talk
Last night to my own laboratory group
There was a very good paper lately
On uh
The
The record of GMO crops
In terms of pesticide use
To use more
To use less
These better kinds of chemicals
And the reality is it's a mixed bag
We're doing all that
Depending on the crop
And the time frame
And it's just that's the reality of it
But we know there's also
Billions and benefits to the economy
We know there's also
Improved soil as a result
So what's the right answer?
So if you like
Instead of simple answers
This is not the area for you
So that's you know that's
So that's sort of
I tried to
When I speak about impeach about it
I try to give students a sense of both
The frustration and anger
At this simple-minded
Social response
No GMO labels
Organic certification
You know I'm cleaner and better than you
And a big reason of that
People go to organic now
So avoid GMOs
Regulations are so intense
That breeders like me
I could be breeding populace
For Oregon
Using GMO techniques
Except that it cost me
A hundred million dollars
To release one variety
Even if with CRISPR
It's just like
On the other hand
You know we have companies
Overusing herbicides
And creating herbicide-resistant weeds
So it's just
Really complicated and difficult
So my own personal point of view
Is don't throw out the baby with the bath water
You know
Take some intelligent middle ground
But that's not where society's at
In terms of marketing and labels
That's not where regulations tend to be
The regulations reflect people's fears
Regulators like to say they're science-based
No where are they really science-based
They try
They're always trying
But the political pressure is incredible
In the US and in Europe
To actually make a science-based decision
The activist groups
Work so hard to influence the science
To get their people
On the boards
And to change the way decisions are made
So again, you know, I was so
I used to be a member of Greenpeace
And they were a club and friends of the earth
And all these guys
And now I wouldn't give them a dollar
So you know
That's where I started
Right
And now I don't trust them
I give a lot of money
To a certain environmental organizations
Like the Nature Conservancy
That are really science-based
But these guys are not
So who's the good guys anymore
So anyway
In the whole food
GMO food biotechnology
Or you get all that
The good guys are the bad guys
The bad guys are the good guys
How do you decide
Yeah
I have a note here to ask you about
The future of forests
Yeah
Right
Which is a big question
But yeah
And here you talk
It feels to me like
A lot of what you're doing now
You're creating work that might be used
In the future in a different environment
Yeah
And I think that's right
Is it fair to assume
You think that the future of forests
Might on some all would depend upon
genetic engineering
Well you know, I've made the argument
One thing you have in the world
With climate change
With people traveling around the world
With pests evolving ever more fast
The stresses on forests are enormous
There is you know
Various papers recording
You know the hundreds
Introduced and new pests
That are damaging forests everywhere
It's an incredible difficult thing
And you know
The main way we deal with that
Is through biocontrol
Conventional breeding
But sometimes those don't work
And so one case
You may know the story of the American chestnut
I don't know if you're familiar with that
It's a species
That was a dominant species
Much like Douglass fur around here
All over the East Coast
Entirely destroyed by an exotic fungus
And so that was a hundred years ago
And now people have been working
Through conventional breeding
And biocontrol to the story
And so far not much left
And so a scientist
In a state University of New York
Has found
He studied the mechanism of disease
The pathogenesis
How it really works
And it's like other pathogens
Where he's found that they produce
This thing called oxalic acid
That actually
Is what kills the tissues
It produces oxalic acid
It kills the tissues
And the fungus acts
As kind of a
Saperified and just basically eats the dead tissue
And he said, well if we can just
Get rid of their oxalic acid
Or turn it way down
Maybe we'll turn it from a pathogen
Into a saprified
It'll still be around
But
I'm talking really damaged trees
So he did
He's done that
Kind of an amazing thing
He took a gene from wheat
In fact
Put it into chestnut
And
He's appeared to be resistant
So there's a case
Where genetic engineering
was important
And it was able to very, very quickly
Do what breeding other techniques couldn't do
And so that's kind of
A well-known case
But then we have lots of other species
That are sort of an earlier stages
Of that same devastation
There's an emerald ash borer
There's hemlocked delgit
A few other things around the world
That are in that category
What looks really bad for the species
So from my point of view
When you have a crisis like that
You want to use all your tools
And genetic engineering is definitely one
Where you come in
You don't say well
What genetic variation the tree species has
Is going to have to be good enough
You say
What are all the tools I have
And if a guy
Stay University of New York
Or elsewhere
Says I think I understand how this pathogen works
Let's take a gene
And move it
Let's tweak a native gene
Maybe we have
We do have some things
That are somewhat similar in chestnut
But we need to edit it
We need to do crisper to change it
And let's do it faster
Because this is an emergency
To get this out and start testing it
Right?
We can't wait
For 20 years of regulatory analysis
And ecological approval
But we can't do that
Can't do that today
Because of the rules
And the regulations
And people's phobias
And the inability of companies
To see that
They could ever use such a tree
So there's almost no investment
In that kind of technology
And to me
That makes no sense
That's just
You know
When you're
You know the line between precaution and paranoia
Procution is sort of
You know taking intelligent measures
To you know look before you leave
Paranoia is being so afraid
And building an institutional system
That's based on fear
And that's
I think that's where our app
With genetic engineering
And it makes no sense
So
You know
Anyway
So I think it could be a powerful technology
For the future
All trees could be semi-dwarf
In a future time
If people were to actually allow that to happen
And maybe they'd be more productive
And more stress-resistant
But we're not going to know in my lifetime
If that's true or not
So you know
So I think there's powerful things we can do
That I think the uses would be selective
These really more egregious cases
That I mentioned
Because conventional breeding is very powerful
And there's essentially no limits on it
You could take a species from anywhere on the world
And move it here to Oregon
And if it works
You know it's fine
So that's radical genetic engineering really
And we can do that
Without any constraints
But if you tweak a genium
There's these huge constraints and issues
So why
Mess with tweaking genes
When you can do that other stuff
So you know
We sort of paint that ourselves into this corner
If you want
You know a bit
So
The graduate students
I assume come to your lab
Because they're attracted by your work
And want to pursue similar topics
What do you tell them?
I mean it sounds to me like
Yeah
You hit a time period of
Of cultural history
I suppose
Where you can do the work that you did
But that window is closed
Well I tell them
You know
I tell them
If you think you're going to graduate
And get a job in the forest industry
Doing biotechnology
The job opportunities are extremely small
So I tell them
You have to be competitive
With any agricultural biotechnologist
You need to be able to get a job
One of those companies
Or at the USDA
That's still doing some of this
Particularly for serious diseases
And you need to have
What I call
Bioinformatics training
Meaning that
You know
Putting the GMO thing aside
You need to be able to do
State-of-the-art computational biology
Which doesn't involve GMOs
Because that's the entry to
Where most jobs are
The broad area of biotech science
So
But otherwise
A lot of them come to me
Because they're motivated
By the things we're talking about
They want to see the world change
Because they see how powerful
Genetic engineering is
They see all of this information out there
Including from the good guys
And they're
Angry and they're passionate
So you know
I tell them
I always wide open
This is the reality
So that's what they say
But again
It's really critical
They do state-of-the-art work
It just happens to be on trees
And then they're going to post-doc
And they'll be able to move into other areas
A couple of concluding questions
I'm interested in your perspective
On change in the College of Forestry
That changes very
Visible to everybody right now
It's as a big homework
P.V. Hall used to be
But tell me how the college has changed
And moved in different directions
And the years of your association
Yeah, you know
I think we have a great leader
And you know
Dean Thomas Matt
It's very visionary
Who really wants to move the college ahead very
Powerfully he wants to sort of move into the environmental mainstream
If he can
He's trying to build much better bridges with
Environmental organizations
And we've had historically
He wants to reduce
The polarization we've had
Amongst the
More in pro-industry
And the pro-environment folks
And I think that's happening over time successfully
He wants to move into the
This advanced, you know, laminated
Technologies
And this new building that's, you know,
A big part of the money
And the push is to do that kind of thing
I think that's really positive
College is also now in different parts of campus
And that's heard sort of a sense of unity that we have
So, you know
I think he's trying to set us on the right path
And do the right thing
And I hope he can bring his vision through the
Completion
But I think that's sort of unknown right now
What kind of impact do you think the new forestry complex
Might have on the college?
Well, you know, I think new buildings
I've been discussing this with various colleagues
It was obviously a big cost
And uh, but you know, the environment
You live and work in matters
It matters to how you feel
How you interact with people
I'm in Richardson Hall, which was about
It was 15 or 19 years old
But it was designed with lots of light, lots of wood
And it's brought people together
It's been, even though I had its own little design flaws
We found out, I expect that
Keeping out things like rain
You know, it's a really beautiful environment
And so I think he wants to take that to another level
And create really a sense of greenness and collaboration
And, you know, an innovation that I think a new building helps to motivate
So, you know, I like the idea
And I, you know, I think there was criticism about
Whether it was green enough and how green you need to be
To tear down an existing functional building
But also quite old-fashioned
And not a great collaborative space at all
Very much in the old model
People basically infile cabinets
So, uh, you know, I think they, I think they're not a lot to try to
Be green while also making it something you can sell to donors
Because donors don't want to invest in, you know
Changing the sighting and existing building
If they want to invest in a vision
And so, I think he didn't really have the choice
But to create a new building
So, uh, now I'm hoping that, you know, that
The dean comes back and the building is as beautiful
And as functional as he hopes it will be
And helps, you know, bring us to another level
So, but right now I think we're in this kind of precarious place
Where a year or two out
I'm happy in that building
And I'll build in projects I know of
It costs more than you think
And then you have to make difficult decisions
As you go and does it actually do everything you thought you were going to do with it
So, I think there's those risks as well
But, uh, tell them, I'm hoping
Yeah
And my last question for you
This is a sesquicentennial project
And then I'm interested in your point of view on the university
As it looks towards its 150th birthday
Where do you think OSU is positioned right now
Yeah, I've, uh, I really felt
Really fortunate to be part of this institution
For the 30, I think I'm going on my 30th first year that I've been here
I've, uh, felt the leadership that I've had in the college of FAR
She's been excellent
Uh, John Barr and Ed Ray
I think have been, you know, inspiring and responsible leaders
Um, I have not gotten involved in administration significantly
So, like, every other faculty member I know of
I wonder if we are investing far too much
Uh, given our limited state budgets in administrators
They just seem to be everywhere
So I wonder whether, uh, every administrator is really needed
And what they're doing
What their impact is
Uh, but in general I like the ethics and the structure of the place
And I'm proud to be a part of it
So, um, you know, I, uh, I like the emphasis that we have on equity and diversity here
And I think that's really important, you know, Oregon is a very white place
And it's a white place for institutional reasons
And in my opinion, those need to be corrected and addressed
So I'm proud that we're doing that
Pretty actively, we're doing them pretty actively in forestry as well
So I think that's the right thing to do
Um, uh, so, you know, in general
I feel good about it
I would love to see more, uh, of the administration
Explain who they are, what they do
And how cost effective they are
And they don't seem to feel they need to do it
So, I don't think that's right
So in that regard, you know, I would love a little bit more of a business sense of
Explaining to faculty
How they're making smart decisions and what
The administrative decisions that they make really cost
As compared to, you know, I don't know, uh, could we have
10% less administration, 10% or 50% more faculty members
Doing innovative research and teaching
I, you know, I just, those trade-offs, I don't understand them
And I don't know anybody does because I don't think administrators
Feel the need to explain them to plebians like me
And I know I don't like that
So, uh, anyway, but so in general, very positive
But, you know, with some sense that maybe
We have some runaway administrative investments
And I think that's a common problem in higher education
You know, so, uh, as far as I understand it
So how do you, how do you reign that in or how do you at least understand it
And decide if you agree with it or not
Um, yeah, certainly not the first time I've heard that
Yeah, yeah, but in short, I mean, I feel privileged to have been here
The community has been an extraordinary place for me to live
And raised my children and, uh, you know, as, uh, when I go back to my
Yale reunions and those folks are all over the world
And they say, hey, you know, you traveled everywhere
Where, where, where would be your ideal place to live?
I always say, I'm living there
I've traveled the world too, and this is an incredible place to be
Well, that's a good, a good enough to stop on
Thank you very much
I really appreciate this